you left the seat up again do you know
what this means I can go skiing without
buying lift tickets check the weather in
Aspen yo so I was flying Easter day and
saw this crazy goose in my gosh Eli we
get it you can fly stop bragging sorry
oh it's annoying
well psyche bombs in Japan in ten
minutes
see yeah you know I can play guitar but
you don't hear me bragging about it when
you go to John or the club or bar what
do you want to look at me down for
Halloween holy [ __ ] cuffs come in yeah
so what'd you get me for Christmas
hohoho
Santa's in town yes who again can you
call first Valentine's Day
ladies ladies I agree Jared you were
without a doubt the most qualified
candidate for this promotion so we're
gonna go to you even eat it nice to
finally meet you how are you I'm good
why is she not wearing sandals I want to
see her feet I just remembered that I
left my dishwasher on so I gotta go I
should just face it I'll never have the
courage to ask her out too much of a
nerd I only ask about pens I could look
deeply into his eyes puny human all dogs
are actually aliens here to destroy the
earth we are going to burn your entire
civilization and you are the only human
being I've told this to we have
hypnotized every last one of them
Wow